- So, there's been a lot of
talk about Nepo babies recently,
so kids of successful people
who also find success.
You have an interesting take on this
and I love your take on this.
Can you tell everybody?
- Yeah.
You know, it's, I'm forever grateful
for everything that my dad had to do
to get me the opportunities that I have.
- Yeah.
- And if I were to run away
from that or shy away from it
in any way, in my eyes,
that's disrespectful to
everything he had to go through.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- He didn't work as hard as he did
for me to not accept and appreciate it.
And so, I wear it as a badge of honor.
A lot of people when
they see me naturally,
"Hey, you're Ice Cube's son."
You damn right I am,
like 100% that's my hero.
- That's so cool.
- That's my culture.
And you know, at the same
time the door can be open,
but you gotta walk through it.
You know, I have a lot of people,
they have an idea of what I'm gonna be
before I get to any set
because of their idea of what my dad is.
- Yeah.
- They think I'm coming
to set feeling entitled
or I feel like I need
to have quote unquote
a posse of 15, 20 people
with me, straight rap stuff.
- Yeah.
- But no, I'm here to work, you know.
I pride myself on my professionalism
and I'm a Kobe fan and
Kobe taught me work ethic.
You gotta grind mama mentality.
And actually one thing,
the late great Kobe Bryant told me
'cause he's in the same thing as me
as far as following
his father's footsteps.
He said, "Your parents
are never gonna want you
to go through anything.
They're never gonna want
you to have hard times,
but you have to pick yourself up.
You have to grind.
You have to take the risk.
And you gotta make a name for yourself."
And that's what I try to do every day.
- I love that.